bon
vu trois messages écrits je suis rien je
vois d'ici c'est quoi montre nous t3
d'année sms
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas
d'accord les trois derniers essais mais
c'est trop pour
moi pas de secret
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chérie s'il vous plaît allez chacun de
ces projets j'y vais je te donne mon
dernier données sms moi je salut salut
mon frérot je parle à amauri qui leur en
régie la salut mon frérot est ce qu'il
ya de la place pour pouvoir rentrer ma
voiture non il n'ya pas de place au quai
poteau mais j'éprouve pour y rentrer et
à quoi sert la belgique
amaury si jérémy non j'attends mon cap
géré m léa le sujet sur le prix de
l'essence nico merci à toi antoine
kukeli je te mets un choeur axa pour
signer les documents d'axa
avait assuré qu'au
mont nouveaux logements a
dit la stib et de l'ailé
vous alors vous c'est ton
gsm s de mon mari qui me dit avant que
tu dises des conneries sur le prix du
gasoil donc voilà un message de paix du
cabaret est un message d'amour et
apparemment je n'écris tout amoureux
et très bon gars et va se marier je
crois oui mais c'est pas grave
[Musique]
surtout que c'est surtout qu'il ya 25
ans
les 25 ans
si on est sur une séquence merci
géraldine alors inona coucou ilona
puisque
nombre de chefs travailler avec amauri
ah oui ensuite à ma fille je lui dis est
ce que tu es passé au filage gros bisous
merci ma gni fi que j'appelle lui aussi
mais ce matin' on s'en fou et ensuite je
préfère maquereau au mouvement mon amour
alors oui je donne expéditeurs sécurité
votre mec ça oui ah oui mon amour oui
alors vu qu'elle appelle mon amour bah
je sais pas moi c'est pas dans le milieu
dans le chèque dans le show me your
j'arrive cetera mais alors delphine tu
m'excite
[Applaudissements]
magic
dispose ce soir à prêter pmp ça c'est
quelqu'un d'autre et et puis là c'est
qui ça c'est qu'ils à ses expéditeurs
inconnus
les pêcheurs ou des podiums à
utilisation intégrale du cif
a connu six voilà quoi moi les trois
gamins
gdri écrit alors moi c'est s'est alors
jetée mieux que rien pas du tout la gata
audrey ok pour demain c'est pour moi bah
oui elle sera dans l'émission
100 minutes à roche qui veulent
m'envoyer ne te laisse pas faire
oui
wahaha
pas du tout parce qu'il ya des trucs oui
mais la grande littérature là avant
alors mes joues mais n'ont rien à y dire
je t'aime
je t'aime alors je vous dire qu'ici je
sais pas mais c'est qui voilà je t'aime
c'est qu'il est au thème vous êtes pas
dit ça va oui c'est un garçon
apparemment
assez bouder voilà bouder quand je
t'aime oui vous avez littéralement
trichez pas du tout ce chemin pour y
regarder mais je vous jure tir mais
hélas c'est duke genthod qui me mais
j'ai envie de paix chaudhry en
voilà et là ça continue site est dispo
demain j'ai de bons joueurs qui veulent
se mesurer à nous voilà un garçon nu et
du paddle voilà voilà très bien mon ami
la zone i lé boeing en valais bowie mais
les riches et les brumes serait que vous
citez tir extrêmement intéressant à
l'intérêt d'axa un texto pizza
la pizza avec en choix elle est gratuite
et à bien nous casser oui et non mais
attends c'est moi